THE CHOICE IS CLEAR, FLORIDA,
GILLUM WILL RUIN YOUR STATE.
YOUR SAFETY, YOUR SECURITY, YOUR
ECONOMY, ARE ON THE LINE IN 14
DAYS, TO GO WEEKS FROM, YOU
DECIDE MAXINE WATERS, ADAM
SCHIFF, AND ALL CHAIR
COMMITTEES, IF YOU WANT THOSE
PEOPLE HOLDING THE TRUMP AGENDA
HOSTAGE, VOTE FOR A DEMOCRAT IS
A VOTE FOR ANY OF THE PEOPLE
YOU SEE ON THE SCREEN PIER
JOINING US NOW, RNC CHAIRWOMAN
RONNA McDANIEL'S WITH US, THE
AUTHOR OF "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
BEST SELLER, THE DEEP STATE,
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR JASON
CHAFFETZ.
WHAT HAPPENS IF THEY WIN?
>> THOSE PEOPLE BECOME CHAIRMAN.
YOU HAVE TO REFER TO MAXINE
WATERS AS CHAIRMAN.
AND ADAM SHIFT WILL DISPLACED
DEVIN NUNES.
AND ALL OF THOSE INVESTIGATIONS
THAT YOU SEE JIM JORDAN AND MARK
MEADOWS AND RADCLIFFE AND GAUDI,
THOSE GO AWAY, BECAUSE THEY ARE
GOING TO DISMISS THOSE AND
YOU WILL GET ELIJAH CUMMINGS AND
YOU WILL GET JERRY NADLER, THE
POWER OF SUBPOENA TO GO AFTER
THIS ADMINISTRATION DAY AFTER
DAY.
>> Sean: RONNA McDANIEL'S, I
FEEL BETTER ABOUT THE SENATE.
I DON'T HAVE A CRYSTAL BALL, AS
I DO ABOUT THE HOUSE.
82 PERCENT CHANCE THE
REPUBLICANS KEEP THE SENATE,
86 PERCENT CHANCE THEY LOSE THE
HOUSE BUT HE WAS LONG AND 2016,
IS IRAN TONIGHT?
>> I THINK HE IS WRONG, SEAN.
THEY'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT THIS
BLUE WAVE OVER AND OVER AND OVER
AGAIN.
WE ARE NOT SEEING IT.
WE ARE NOT SEEING IT IN THE
EARLY VOTING IN FLORIDA, NEVADA,
STATES THAT WE ARE ALREADY
SEEING RESULTS COME IN, AND
CERTAINLY ON THE SENATE SIDE, WE
ARE SEEING LEADS OPEN UP IN
NORTH DAKOTA AND MISSOURI AND
INDIANA, SO THERE IS GREAT
OPPORTUNITIES TO PICK UP SEATS,
BUT YOU ARE RIGHT, WE HAVE TO
GET OUT AND VOTE.
WHAT YOU JUST TALKED ABOUT, WHAT
WOULD HAPPEN IF WE LOSE THE
HOUSE, I KNOW IT IS NOT
HALLOWEEN YET, BUT A SHIVER JUST
WENT DOWN MY SPINE.
WE HAVE TWO GET ALL OF OUR
VOTERS OUT THERE.
IT IS NOT A DONE DEAL, THE
DEMOCRATS ARE ENERGIZED, THE
ONLY WAY WE KEEP THE HOUSE IS IF
WE GET OUR VOTERS OUT PAIRED
TALK TO YOUR FAMILY, TALK TO
YOUR FRIENDS.
GET EVERYONE OUT TO THE POLLS.
WE ARE FIGHTING FOR OUR FUTURE.
WE KNOW WHAT NANCY PELOSI MEANS
PAY HIGHER TAXES, ABOLISH
I.C.E., OPEN BORDERS, ADMIRING
OUR COUNTRY DOWN AN
INVESTIGATION AFTER
INVESTIGATION.
>> Sean: KEEP OBAMACARE, THAT
IS NOT A RADICAL AGENDA, JASON
CHAFFETZ BIT >> NO, IT IS THERE
THAT WANT TO RAISE TAXES,
ABOLISH I.C.E., THEY WANT THE
OPEN BORDERS, THEY DON'T
ANNOUNCE ANY OF THE VIOLENCE,
THEY STAND FOR THE RESISTANCE
MOVEMENT, THEY WANT SCORCHED
EARTH.
THEY ARE GOING TO DELIVER WHAT
THEY ARE PROMISING.
WE SHOULD BELIEVE THEM.
>> Sean: ALL OF THESE PEOPLE,
THEY ARE NOT TELLING THEIR
AGENDA.
MAXINE, SCIOSCIA, EVEN
JOHN PODESTA, DON'T TALK ABOUT
IMMIGRATION.
NOT ONE DEMOCRAT TALKS ABOUT THE
CARE OF AND HEADING TO THE SOLAR
BORDER BECAUSE THEY WANT OPEN
BORDERS, SUPPORT AMNESTY,
CENTURY CITIES AND STATES.
THAT IS WHAT THEY REALLY WANT,
BUT THEY ARE NOT SAYING IT.
PHIL BREDESEN GOT CAUGHT CALLING
THE PEOPLE OF TENNESSEE
IGNORANT, WE KNOW THAT
McCASKILL GOT CAUGHT SAYING,
I'M ANTIGUN, ALL PRO EVERYTHING
OBAMA BELIEF.
HEIDI HEITKAMP'S STAFF THINK SHE
WILL BE A SUPER LIBERAL.
THANK GOD ProjectVeritas.com
GOT THE STATE.
>> THEY ARE THE LIARS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP DELIVERED ON
PROMISES FROM THE CAMPAIGN
TRAIL, BE OF DEMOCRAT OR
DEMOCRAT CAUGHT IN A LINE.
RUNNING ON ONE THING, SAYING
ELECT ME, AND THEN I GET THERE,
I'LL GOVERN WITH CHUCK SCHUMER
AND NANCY PELOSI.
NANCY PELOSI HAS SAID VERY
CLEARLY, YOU HAVE A FREE PASS,
RUN AGAINST ME, SAY YOU WON'T
VOTE FOR ME FOR SPEAKER, BECAUSE
I KNOW WHEN YOU COME HOME, YOU
ARE GOING TO VOTE FOR
NANCY PELOSI, WHICH WOULD BE A
DISASTER.